THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU JOINING
US THIS EVENING.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE VICE
PRESIDENT SPEAKING OUT ABOUT
THE, ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
WATCH AND THEN WE'LL TALK.
>> AS I SAID THAT DAY, JANUARY
6th WAS A DARK DAY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL.
BUT THANKS TO THE SWIFT ACTION
OF THE CAPITOL POLICE AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT,
VIOLENCE WAS QUELLED.
THE CAPITOL WAS SECURED.
AND THAT SAME DAY WE RECONVENED
THE CONGRESS AND DID OUR DUTY
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I
HAVE SPOKEN MANY TIMES SINCE WE
LEFT OFFICE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL EVER
SEE EYE TO EYE ON THAT DAY.
>> SO HE SAYS THAT HE MIGHT
NEVER SEE EYE TO EYE WITH TRUMP
ON JANUARY 6th.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS STORY?
>> WELL, THAT IS CERTAINLY TRUE.
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO SEE EYE
TO EYE.
PENCE UPHELD THE CONSTITUTION
AND TRUMP WAS READY TO DISBAR
HIM.
AND THAT'S JUST REMARKABLE HOW
PENCE CAN SAY, WE'RE HAVING, WE
WON'T SEE EYE TO EYE ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL
THING YOU CAN POSSIBLY DISAGREE
ABOUT.
IF YOU ARE A PUBLIC OFFICIAL OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
PARTICULARLY, THE TWO HIGHEST
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
WE WON'T SEE EYE TO EYE.
ONE IS TALKING ABOUT
OVERTHROWING THE CONSTITUTION.
ONE WAS TRYING TO OVERTHROW
CONSTITUTION BY ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO MARCH UP TO CAPITOL
HILL SO THEY COULD STOP THE
COUNTING OF THE ELECTORAL VOTES.
THE OTHER MAN TO HIS CREDIT,
UPTHEY TOLD CONSTITUTION AND DID
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY.
THIS IS SAYING, THEY DON'T SEE
EYE TO EYE ON IT LIKE IT IS
ANOTHER DISAGREEMENT ABOUT
POLICY IS KIND OF A REMARKABLE,
REMARKABLE UNDERSTATEMENT, IF
YOU WILL, OF WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WE DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE ON
THE MOB THAT YOU INCITED TO COME
AND WANTED TO KILL ME.
YEAH.
>> EXACTLY.
HANG MIKE PENCE, THEY WERE
CHANNELLING.
IT IS INCREDIBLE.
INCREDIBLE TO WATCHFUL BUT PENCE
DESERVES CREDIT FOR DOING UNDER
ENORMOUS PRESSURE, DOING THE
RIGHT THING THAT DAY.
HE DID THE RIGHT THING.
HE DESERVES CREDIT FOR THAT.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
NATIONAL REPORTING.
CHARLES COOK IS BACKING UP
MAGGIE HABERMAN, SAYING THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT REALLY BELIEVES
HE WILL BE REINSTATED.
HE ADDS THAT CONSERVATIVES
SHOULD NOT BRUSH THIS OFF.
LET ME QUOTE HERE.
SUCH TEMPTATIONS SHOULD BE
AVOIDED.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT A
FRINGE FIGURE WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN TENT BUT ABOUT A MAN
WHO HOPES TO MAKE SUPPORT AS HE
DECIDES WHOM TO ENDORSE IN 2022
AND 2024.
MOST REPUBLICANS AREN'T STANDING
UP TO TRUMP EVEN THOUGH SOME AT
LEAST SEEM LEGITIMATELY ALARMED.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> THEY'RE JUST AFRAID OF TRUMP.
THEY'RE AFRAID OF TRUMP AND
THEY'RE AFRAID OF HIS
SUPPORTERS.
THE LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE BEEN
DECEIVED BY TRUMP, OR WILLINGLY
DECEIVED, FRANKLY.
AND THEY ARE, THEY FEAR THIS MAN
WHO COST THEM THE PRESIDENCY,
COST THEM THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IN 2018, COST
THEM SENATE IN 2021.
AND YOU KNOW, HE'S NUTS.
ABSOLUTELY CRACKERS.
I MEAN, FOR HIM TO BE GOING
AROUND SAYING THAT HE'S GOING TO
BE REINSTATED IN AUGUST.
I MEAN, THAT'S CUCKOO FOR COCOA
PUFFS.
AND YET THEY ARE TERRIFIED OF
HIM.
>> A BETTER QUESTION IS HOW
SERIOUSLY SHOULD WE TAKE THIS?
BECAUSE LISTEN.
I WALKED TO THE BARBER SHOP IN
NEW YORK CITY AND THERE WERE
PEOPLE TALKING TO EACH OTHER ON
THE STREET.
BUT I'M NOT PUTTING THEM ON
TELEVISION, I'M NOT EXPLOITING
THEM BY PUTTING THEM ON
TELEVISION AND REPORTING THEM.
YOU SAID CUCKOO FOR COCOA PUFFS.
HOW SERIOUSLY SHOULD WE BE
TAKING THE RANTINGS WITH SOMEONE
NOT DEALING WITH REALITY?
>> BOTH NOT SERIOUS JUSTLY AND
SERIOUSLY.
NOT SERIOUSLY IN THAT IT WON'T
HAPPEN.
THERE IS NO MECHANISM BY WHICH
IT COULD HAPPEN.
SERIOUSLY IN THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY PEDDLING THIS.
THERE IS A WHOLE CONSERVATIVE
ECOSYSTEM THAT HAS DEVELOPED OF
DISINFORMATION THAT WASHEIMER
CHARGED BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
AND HE'S GETTING THIS FROM
SOMEWHERE.
AND WE HEARD SOME OF IT FROM THE
CRAZY LAWYER, WHAT'S HER NAME.
>> SYDNEY POWELL?
>> AND WE HEARD THIS BIZARRE
STATEMENT OVER THE WEEKEND BY
MICHAEL NINE.
AND THIS STUFF IS OUT THERE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
MAY BELIEVE THIS.
AND YOU'VE SEEN THE POLLS ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, SOME SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE OF REPUBLICANS, I
DON'T KNOW, 10 OR 20% BELIEVING
IN QANON.
THIS IS THE SAME THING.
HE'S A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE HASN'T UTTERED THIS PUBLICLY
BUT HIS PEOPLE HAVEN'T DENIED
THAT HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS WITH PEOPLE.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE HASN'T
BEEN DENIED TELLS THAT YOU THERE
IS SOMETHING TO THE FACT THAT HE
IS HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
SO ON ONE LEVEL, YOU HAVE TO
TAKE IT WITH A GRAIN OF SALT
BECAUSE IT IS COMPLETELY NUTS.
ON ANOTHER LEVEL, THE FACT THAT
ENOUGH PEOPLE MIGHT BE WILLING
TO BELIEVE, ARE WILLING TO
BELIEVE THE BIG LIE OF 2020,
THAT THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND
MIGHT, YOU KNOW, BELIEVE THAT
SOMEHOW DONALD TRUMP SHOULD BE
RESTORED TO HIS PROPER PLACE IN
THE PRESIDENCY.
WE SAW THE VIOLENCE ON JAB 6th.
IT COULD BE VIOLENCE AGAIN.
>> REMEMBER, I SAID PEOPLE ON
THE STREET, I MEBLT PEOPLE
TALKING TO THEMSELVES ON THE
STREET.
I DON'T EXPLOIT THEM BY PUTTING
THEM TO TELEVISION BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER HELP SAYING THERE
ARE PEOPLE WITH ISSUES.
DONALD TRUMP HAS AN ISSUE.
HE THINKS -- LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE MAIN REASON WE HAVE YOU
HERE.
THIS IS IN YOUR MAIN PIECE IN
THE "WASHINGTON POST."
IT SAID THE SENATE GOP HAD NO
REASON TO BLOCK THIS JANUARY 6th
COMMISSION.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
FOUR YEARS OF TRUMP HAVE LED THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, A DECLINING
SECT DOMINATED BY CRACK POTS,
CHARLOTTANS AND COWARDS.
AMONG THEM, THEY BARE THE MOST
BLAME.
HOW DO YOU NEGOTIATE WITH THESE
WHO ARE NOT ACTING IN GOOD FAITH
AND NOT IN REALITY AS WELL?
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THAT AFTER THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION, THEY WOULD FINALLY
HAVE BEEN DONE WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
AND IT ALMOST SEEMED LIKE THEY
WERE.
AND EVEN AFTER THEY ACQUITTED
HIM IN THE SECOND IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL, YOU HAD MITCH McCONNELL
IMMEDIATELY GOING TO THE FLOOR
OF THE SENATE AND TALKING ABOUT
WHAT A TERRIBLE THING TRUMP DID
THE THAT DAY.
THAT HE WAS DARRELL 96th HIS
DUTIES.
THAT HE WAS GLEEFULLY WATCHING
THE VIOLENCE ON TELEVISION.
AND YOU THOUGHT MAYBE THEY WERE
TURNING CORNER EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE USED TO CONVICT TRUMP ON
THE MERITLESS THEORY THAT YOU
CAN'T CONVICT A FORMER PRESIDENT
AND BAR HIM FROM OFFICE.
THERE WAS SOME BASIS TO BELIEVE
THAT MAYBE THEY HAD TURNED THE
CORNER ON HIM AND NOW THEY DON'T
WANT TO EVEN TALK ABOUT IT.
THIS VOTE LAST WEEK DIDN'T ASK
THEM TO DO ANYTHING OTHER THAN
LET SOMEBODY ELSE LOOK INTO THE
FACTS.
AND THEY'RE SO TERRIFIED THAT
MORE FACTS WILL COME OUT ABOUT
WHAT DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING ALL
DAY IN THE OVAL OFFICE WHILE HE
WAS WATCHING TV, AND THE
VIOLENCE WAS UP ON THE HILL.
THEY'RE SO AFRAID OF BEING
TARRED BY THAT.
THEY HAVE A REASON TO BE AFRAID
OF BEING TARRED BY IT.
THEY LET THIS GUY STAY IN OFFICE
BY NOT REMOVING HIM THE FIRST
TIME AND THEY